thank you ah spring has sprung here huh
oh i appreciate it
thank you very much i i could see the uh
happiness the enthusiasm
the love because thank you and we are
getting back to normal i see it
everywhere
the traffic is heavier restaurants are
open republicans pretend to give
a [ __ ] about the debt again i i it's
i feel like any minute pam anderson
could remarry kid rock
things are just returning
and listen to this to the cdc they said
that you know the distancing rule they
have for kids
school kids which has been six feet now
three feet
moving in the right direction in florida
the students are hopeful that by fall
they'll be back inside their teachers
it's uh oh i
kid florida but
of course with us reopening it brings
other issues we have a surge of migrants
at the border and the authorities say we
cannot take any more
any more uh unskilled foreigners who
don't even seem like they want to work
we already have megan and harry that
that's
and uh oh that's a good crowd
good crowd good crowd
should give out treats when they laugh
at the laugh at the politically
incorrect ones good
uh but here's something interesting i
read about the pandemic that were
hopefully coming out of it during this
last year they say this survey is found
the average single person has been
masturbating three times a day
[Applause]
i don't know who this is exactly i
assume it's the guy in the zoom meeting
who claims he's petting his cat
i assume
i no well
of course this doesn't really reveal
anything about human nature we don't
already know but it does explain why
costco is always out of kleenex
but hey biden's kind of kicking ass you
know they've uh
uh well you know his big thing was i'm
gonna get a hundred
when he that was his big thing i'm gonna
get a hundred million vaccines out and
100 he's way had 97 million vaccines
have gone 2 million a day now
trump said oh sure if you want to show
off government that tries
[Music]
now biden promised a hundred million in
a hundred days way ahead of that
schedule of course
uh you have to understand this is a guy
who eats dinner at 5 p.m
so well one reason why they're doing so
well with that is they expanded the list
of who can give shots dentists
did you know that you're getting it for
medical students
midwives midwives anybody had those
veterinarians and that i went to my vet
oh it's fine it's a little different he
gave me the shot and he put a cone on my
neck
[Applause]
but it's fine i mean yes it was
it's a little okay it's a little weird
going to the bed for a shot i had to
trick myself to get into the car but
other than that it's a
but you've read this people are figuring
out ways to jump the vaccine lines oh
yeah
at berkeley now you can get it if your
spiritual advisor says you're an old
soul
that seems wrong in l.a
you get it if your facial filler is
still under warranty
[Applause]
speaking of facial filler the oscar
nominations are out
[Music]
are you excited about that yes the
leading contenders for best picture
are a nomad land minari and the sound of
metal
so for theaters we're trying to figure
out how to reopen at 15
capacity i think we found the answer
you